twitch can be a wild place
as a Creator on the platform you're
constantly navigating the Ebbs and flows
of what's hot and what's not here
that was so gross I was giving you the
whole spoon sometimes it can feel like
the more outrageous you are the more
popular you get
of being the most over-the-top
ridiculous version of yourself one
mini-headed man is booking that Trend by
being nothing if not unapologetically
himself
[Laughter]
on Pika the Turkish American streaming
heartthrob who's become a superstar
despite covering the one thing that
others were sane enough to stay away
from politics believe police have always
overwhelmingly in the highest of
majorities voted for Republicans these
are literally all unaccountable
unelected weaponized
personal and they're all Trump
supporters they're all they're all
psychotic Republican Hogs so how exactly
did Hassan's propensity for political
commentary change twitch how did memes
and an unlikely friendship allow Hassan
to educate the masses on Progressive
topics and ultimately is his tendency
for drama leading him to an early
retirement what a flyer dude what a
Weasley little liar dude
[Music]
before he was throwing together crazy
fits getting stun locked into Oblivion
or raising Millions for charity Hassan
was a young host working for his uncle's
new show however before his career in
broadcasting could truly take off Hassan
chose streaming instead and it turns out
this was the best decision he could have
made because by now chances are you know
him as one of the largest English
language streamers in the world what are
you supposed to do is he supposed to go
on a date and live happily ever after
with with someone that he is not
physically attracted to I find this so
[__] strange because you don't do
that you do not do that so how and why
did Hassan a guy who watches Boomers
debate each other on C-Span all day gets
so big on a platform Infested by Zoomers
you see discussing politics online with
a younger generation can be a difficult
task but thanks in part to his education
and back around in broadcasting Hassan
knew how to tackle some of America's
heaviest topics in a way that was very
easy to understand Marxism is just a
theory on how commodity production Works
under a capitalist organization of the
economy the relationship between those
who produced the work the workers versus
those who uh profit from the labor that
you put in the bourgeoisie the capital
owners but even more importantly Hassan
had the ultimate Zuma bait in his
Arsenal memes in this day and age memes
are a form of cultural currency and as
silly as it sounds a lot of your growth
as a Creator can depend on how well you
can capitalize on that currency and
Hassan's Community were the special
forces of [__] posting the state of
Assange streams gaming frogs -500 drama
frogs 1400 politics frogs a thousand
that's not even true it's not mostly
dramas most in politics and reacts dude
and one meme in particular became
something of a moniker for her son himbo
you see on top of all the other things
I've mentioned Hassan had something else
going for him a secret sauce if you will
look a lot of people find him attractive
it's undeniable that at least some part
of Hassan's popularity is the fact that
he's a charismatic person unfortunately
this ended up being both a blessing and
a curse for Hassan while it definitely
brought him some new fans at times it
seemed like they weren't exactly there
for the politics
I don't know what this is
hold off
Roth girl stepped in piercings and bangs
I mean I like everything dude I'm equal
opportunity wait now I want to see what
she's gonna do now
is he gonna like me now please
but Hassan did find a way to use this to
his Advantage he basically weaponized
the himbo to put it simply he knew that
even if some people were showing up just
to watch they were still staying for the
discourse the entire family is
ridiculously wealthy and should not she
also had a lot more influence over the
government than people think she did for
the record she made a concerted effort
to thwart Independence movements and
prevent newly independent colonies from
leaving the union from the Commonwealth
true Hassan quickly proved these thirsty
viewers that he was smart well-spoken
and passionate about his beliefs and to
be honest even his haters couldn't
resist do you think Hassan [__] is hot
no
why are you think it's so hard
[Music]
but being a himbo became more than just
a meme for Hassan and his community not
only did Hassan turn into part of his
brand he also used it to redefine the
male identity for his viewers to a lot
of young men in his audience Hassan was
a prime example of what healthy
masculinity could look like and with the
ongoing rise of so-called men's rights
activists Hassan provided a very
different perspective at an important
time I don't know why people make such a
big deal out of this one way or the
other like it's not a big deal either
way and I say this as someone who had so
I had never worn a dress before until
you guys sent me a dress and that shit's
liberating dude like Ben Shapiro could
try as hard as he can to look more
masculine I could try as hard as I can
to look more feminine and I would
probably still look more masculine than
Ben Shapiro it's ridiculous to to assume
that like there is this this binary and
and that like gender expression is
limited Hassan was able to create a
space for open political discourse in
the upper echelons of twitch and Beyond
which inevitably led to the subject
matter becoming less and less taboo on
the platform but amidst Hassan's efforts
to re-educate Twitch one man stood out
as his biggest challenge since the very
beginning the shell on Turtles did they
spawn with it
when the two first met back in 2018 xqc
played every game covered every topic
and had a legion of the most spamming
juicers that hung onto his every word
and his popularity was skyrocketing we
were getting raided by uh the police
station uh at rates that made absolutely
[__] no sense
uh almost every day the the police came
to our house with a full Squad
because of you know
[__] idiots okay and I was really I
was generally scared that I was going to
die to top it all off xqc had a history
of not exactly playing by the rules
which was part of the reason why he was
so popular so whether it was intentional
or not Hassan seemingly made it his
mission to tame xqc after all if he
could get through to chaos personified
he could get through to anyone and
although it seemed like he had his work
cut out for him X seemed genuinely
interested in learning well I'm I'm
doing the gist of it I'm getting like
the counter arguments it's not really
it's not really that I'm arguing it I'm
sort of like and I think it's these
ideas but they have holes in them
because I'm like I have like this sort
of thought but their their Town reacted
by by some of some of your uh your
ancestors I think it's good it turned
out that the two had a lot more in
common than people would have thought
and as their friendship blossomed
Hassan's political opinion started to
rub off on X soon twitch's biggest most
bombastic personality was dishing out
his own nuanced takes on the world's
most divisive issues and he was doing it
in front of his massive audience
like how much would people sell their
time that's what people always do dude
your life
taking people already do that it's
capitalism you [__] idiot
and then the student even began arguing
with the teacher a lot of people
deciding what
Azan because because I didn't apologize
to him and she doesn't act like like a
victim and I'm being a bad friend when
he constantly drags me on social media I
don't get it it doesn't matter xqc is a
child even though he's 27 years old he's
literally a man-child a baby what are
you
[Laughter]
but at the end of the day what truly
mattered was that her son was able to
reach an audience that would have likely
never sought him out on their own and
formed a legitimate friendship along the
way thanks to his efforts we now live in
a world where you can be a Hassan RB
head and a juicer at the same time and
even though their most recent beef
caused a pretty big rift between their
communities it's hard to believe that
these two could ever stay mad at one
another for long one of my favorite
people to hang out with off camera is
Felix
because
I'm just gonna let you juicers in on a
secret okay
he's a
he's a little baby okay he's he's a
[__] sweetheart he's the only one who
checks it on me when things go weird
I don't have a problem with him I love
lasagna but becoming a political [__]
poster and the symbol of socialism on
Twitch came at a cost some of Hassan's
spicier takes were getting a fair bit of
criticism and he had no choice but to
push back a lot of people on Twitter
think that I uh you know bought a house
cash
[Music]
it's because they're [__] stupid
sorry because they're 14 and they're
leftists and they just learned about
Marxism over the course of these
uh past couple of months so of course
they're kind of dumb so whether he was
calling out an ignorant chatter or
fighting an entire Twitter mob as the
controversies piled up it became clear
that Hassan was having trouble taking
things in his stride her whole point is
demotivating people to work
and it's not even true
don't come in here with these [__]
idiotic brain dead I studied econ 101
takes the moral hazards the moral hazard
suck my [__] dick people who think
feminists are the problem are dumb okay
that's the point I'm making why do so
many of you try to actively
undermine everything I [__] say I'm
saying the opposite this is literally
like foundational political Theory okay
please stop [__] diluting serious
analysis by saying murad's bread Theory
okay that's not just murat's brother you
[__] idiots shut the [__] up
shut up shut up
twitch brain rotted dumbasses dude I'm
done I I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm done I'm done for the day I
think I literally have a fever coming on
I'm just I've I've whipped myself into
anger so much now although these
outbursts could be seen as good content
it was also providing his haters with
more ammunition and it began taking a
toll on Hassan's mental health I
normally maybe a younger Hassan would
take the smoke and be like I'm gonna do
it [__] it you suck my dick and make a
lesson out of that but I'm done I'm too
old I've gotten asked by Twitter weirdos
so much that every single time this kind
of [__] heats up in my chat or on
Twitter you see it like you you see the
designated haters that that come
crawling out of the woodwork at the end
of the day Hassan did what no one else
could he came to Twitch as an outsider
and made political commentary cool he
befriended some of the platform's
largest creators and encouraged Their
audience is to engage more with politics
that affect their lives and also this
notion that like left-leaning
investigative reporters thinkers are not
blacklisted from every [__] Outlet by
those who espouse uh the values of
freedom of speech by the way like
friendship people or uh [__] Alan
dershowitz
um these are the guys who Blacklist
people like Norman Finkelstein or
advocate for the Banning of uh of others
uh that uh you know believe in things
such as Palestinians or human beings
like it's it's psychotic but most
importantly Hassan has managed to raise
unbelievable amounts of money for a ton
of different charities and has used his
platform to shed light on important
issues and sure Hassan gets his way
sometimes but his level of passion and
integrity are truly a breath of fresh
air and whether you agree with his views
or not one thing's for certain twitch
would not be what it is today without
Hassan the greatest enemy of leftists or
other left is always uh like when
right-wing [__] say I'm a [__]
rich person who's a piece of [__] or
whatever it doesn't bother me as much as
when I see leftist people who are like
[__] you and it's fine I understand why
you're mad because everyone is against
you I understand why you're mad because
legislation is against you but trust me
like there is no clout to be bad by
defending trans people just like there's
no clout to be hand uh to be had by
defending marginalized communities
there's no clout to be had by being a
[__] socialist
your life is [__] when you do this
it's awful
hence why I don't do it for the cloud I
do it because I believe in it okay
[Music]
I feel like I've seen a lot of clips of
Hassan doing impressions of British
people
and if he watches this on stream
yeah I wonder if he'll do an impression
of me he's always doing a an impression
of a Rouge person he's like hello mate
hello kafner
that kind of impression